[Music]
this year was a great year for anime
Watchers to the point that even fall
alone had its fair share of Epic fights
with the passage of time animation
techniques have gotten better and there
are still stories that can put you on
the edge of your seat but no need to
worry about missing out on at least 10
of these since we put together a list of
the top 10 fights of fall 2023 starting
off we have thorman versus tenu from
Tokyo Avengers our badass main gang
versus the big baddies of this
Arc T
out Tokyo Avengers have had its fair
share of some pretty awesome fights but
the best one in my opinion was when the
outnumbered thorman fought tenjiku even
though the main Powerhouse Mikey wasn't
present at the beginning thorman still
kept up pretty well considering that
this fight was to settle the score
between gaki and isana the stakes were
actually pretty high the setup was very
dramatic and the fight itself was great
although there weren't any Godly
animation sequences or impact frames it
kept the classic fist fight that we
usually see delinquents have a going the
way they set up isana and the entire
fight was awesome and D Mei finally
popped off you can really see how his
character developed from a guy who
pretended he was a delinquent to the
acting president of the Tokyo Mani gang
everyone believed in him that he could
carry thorman on his back and this man
did it with no hesitation at
all but hey have you ever wondered what
it would be like to talk to your
favorite anime character well there's
actually one app that might help you and
it's the sponsors of this video talki
it's a great AI chat companion
application that can actually just mimic
almost any anime character you want you
can even personalize it by adding some
custom data to the AI conversation
models or if you want you can talk to
models made by other people when making
your own characters you can give Life by
personalizing their visuals narratives
voices and even conversation Styles you
can also follow the characters you like
so you won't ever have to go through the
trouble of searching for your new
virtual friends ever again this means
you can quite literally talk to eron and
ask him what's his master plan or talk
to your favorite waifu and just have a
nice time and they'll instantly reply I
also found another cool feature where
you can get exclusive cards inspired by
conversations just like any card game
you can also keep on collecting them and
eventually even be able to trade imagine
having an entire roster of wuss it's not
limited to anime 2 because it can be TV
show characters or even straight out of
your imagination you can check toy out
on the IOS app store and Google Play
Store by clicking the link in the
description and comments join me and
let's hop on this free new trend
together maybe you can even fulfill your
childhood dream and talk to Santa coming
up next is sunru versus Lon the
nightslayer from shanga
[Music]
Frontier you know a monster is extremely
powerful when it defeats another monster
that you are having a hard time with
that's what happened to Sonu when Lon
showed up and defeated the difficult Red
Cap Goblin sonru quickly realizes that
this opponent is way out of his league
but that doesn't stop him from taking a
head on the Beast could literally have
killed sonru in a single attack and
that's what made the fight so intense
even more the animators made the Beast
so huge and intimidating with a dark
Aura they even added those critical
texts every time Sonu gets hit which
adds to the gaming Vibes the anime
focuses on it's also not like your
average gaming fantasy anime because
from this fight to load there's little
to no usage of CGI and 3D animation at
all I don't want to spoil the end of the
fight so I'll try to restrain myself a
little bit here but man was it amazing
not a lot of attention has been given to
shanga Frontier but it might just be one
of the most well animated anime this
fall
[Music]
2023 moving on we have Adonis going
absolutely insane in kingdoms of
Ruin now this entry is less of a fight
and more of a
[Music]
massacre but it still deserves a spot on
this list since the humans did
technically try to fight anyone watching
the series knows that Adonis hates
humans after Chloe's execution and this
moment was him showing all of his rage
the entire scene just tears you apart
because as much as you can sympathize
with Adonis there's also the slaughter
of innocent humans but hey we're here
for the Revenge story even though a
giant robot and machine guns may be
Overkill now we know what will happen if
magic and modern weapons finally mix
together overall the animation of this
fight scene may not be as amazing as
some of the other entries on this list
but it holds weight because of the
emotions on display you can clearly see
how adonis's rage drives him but his
inner guil also comes out since he
starts crying after massacring so many
people the character's emotions are
displayed really well and Yokohama
animation laboratory did a fine job of
animating it especially since it's not a
AAA
[Music]
title up next we have an ENT from the
big three of shet anime I wish there was
a way to know you're in the good old
days before you've actually left them
it's one piece greenball versus the
scabbards Yamato and Mos the entirety of
the wano AR was gorgeously animated and
all credit Goes To Toe animation well
most of the credit after Oda of course
the fight between greenbolt the
scabbards Yamato and Mos was as hype as
it was in the manga Admiral green Ball's
first appearance was really intense
since the entire gang had just gotten
done with fighting kaido and his crew so
the stakes were super high this was just
like the time after gecko morio was
defeated but Kuma showed up out of the
blue to absolutely wreck the straw hats
now getting back to the fight it has
stuff like a dragon green ball turning
into a giant tree man ninjas Samurai
animal hybrids just basically everything
so that's awesome in itself but watching
The Admiral display the full extent of
his power the first time he ends up in a
fight is the real cherry on top it was
just a really intense fight where the
straw hats might have had to fight again
if not for a certain red head pipe
look in
[Music]
there blasting their way into the list
we have the primordial demon Violet
versus luminous Valentine from that time
I got reincarnated as a slime vision of
colos now these two are amongst the
strongest in this anime so having the
Two Face Off makes for an amazing fight
seed although it's clear that the two
are more or less just playing around
instead of actually showcasing all of
their power the fight looks absolutely
gorgeous especially how the red and
purple attacks look on screen it's
fast-paced and has some spectacular
animation with the magic looking as good
as the attacks in the main series it's
always awesome seeing a primordial demon
and a Godly vampire fighting the fight
is a bit short so it doesn't fill you up
like you want but it does a fantastic
job of showcasing to us viewers once
about to come in the next
season too bad we don't get to see who
the winner of the fight would be since
both the opponents seem equally
matched
[Music]
byebye and now that we're down to the
top five we have Andy versus Gina in
Undead unluck now what's funny about
this fight was that Gina just never
seemed to let go of her love for Andy
but it was really twisted she wasn't
even done with her monologue and then
Andy just threw explosives at her Gina's
entire ability was
unchanged which was just so overpowered
because she can stop an object from
changing she can make a sword create
barriers and even look young forever the
entire fight was so Dynamic and it was
amazing to see how Andy used his own
body to use really creative attacks not
only that the battle was both awesome
and a little bit funny their Battlefield
the animation and the final blow where
they used fuko's unluck to fire a
literal laser at Gina everything was in
this fight and Gina's death had us feel
some heavy emotions that we wouldn't
have expected from this
[Music]
anime
before we reveal the top three list we
have ragna versus Grim weld from ragar
Crimson now you'd think that dragons are
already a very powerful type of enemy
but then come along Superior dragons as
the title says Superior dragons are more
powerful than the already strong dragons
that our heroes have to fight
unfortunately for ragna not even leonica
is enough to deal with Superior dragons
even though she's currently the strong
strong EST person in the area seeing
that she's going to die something
amazing happens without spoiling
anything major ragar gets a power that
looks amazing on screen it's like
watching Goku transform into a Super
Saiyan if ragna hadn't gotten his power
Leo would have died at the hands of
grimal but even so watching ragna
destroy such a powerful opponent was
extremely satisfying it's also
refreshing to see how ragna wasn't the
wholesome type of MC and he never had
second thoughts when killing his
opponents he freezes everything in his
path and with one flick shates them into
thousands of pieces
[Music]
making way to the top three now we have
Shadow Garden versus John Smith from
Eminence in Shadow what's interesting
about this fight is that John Smith AKA
Shadow is the one who created the Shadow
Garden in the first place although his
opponents didn't know that as he was in
Disguise but still Shadow demonstrated
his power once again while fighting the
Shadow Garden members the animation of
this Series has been amazing and the
choreography of the fight is just Mah
all in all the attention to detail was
to die for we get to see the Gap in
power between Shadow Garden and Shadow
himself and take note that he isn't even
using his nuclear magic in an instant he
was able to trap two members and in the
end Shadow Garden couldn't do anything
but watch John Smith have his
way
[Music]
next up we have freen versus Aura from
freen Beyond Journey's End the main
character of The Show Goes Up Against
the main villain of the arc here pretty
standard stuff until you see how freen
completely overpowered aura that also be
hard pressed to call this a fight scene
since it's pretty much one-sided
everyone who's watched the series
already knows how free and keeps her
Mana suppressed unfortunately for Aura
though she hasn't watched the series
Aura is significantly powerful since she
is one of the seven sages of Destruction
and as the scales of obedience which
allow anyone with more Mana complete
control over the person with less Mana
she tries to use this against freen but
a biggest mistake was underestimating
the greatest grandma in anime the
moment's extremely satisfying as this
super powerful villain is defeated
almost instantly it's an epic moment to
watch and showcases how strong freen
really is the animation is one of the
the best this season especially the
characters auras but the best part was
how frein turned her back before Aura
even died if eradicating demons was a
job then freen would be a
[Applause]
[Music]
Millionaire on the top of this list is a
fight that many people have been waiting
for for sukuna versus mahura from Jutsu
Kaizen sukuna the main antagonist of the
series against the strongest Shiki gami
of all time suffice to say the fight is
just perfect in every way the animation
was Godly and the soundtrack is just so
so good the choreography the camera
angles everything is just so perfect but
would you believe that it's reported
that this episode was only 30% complete
I can't even imagine how it would be at
100% we see Suite in all of his
arrogance as he decimates an opponent
that can adapt to just almost anything
that's thrown his way from start to
finish the fight was pure destruction
obliterating entire blocks of Shibuya
season 2 of Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen may have
been full of amazing fight scenes but
this one is at the top of the season and
our
list
[Applause]
H and with that we wrap up the top 10
fights of fall 2023 with short there
were other fights that you love that
didn't make the list so as always make
sure to let us know down in the comments
and don't forget to check out the
sponsors of this video talkie for some
fun anime AI companion chat links in the
description if you enjoyed this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe if you
want more of this content See you in the
next one